e aí
e esse é o código da vida refere ana
oito anos estudante do terceiro ano de
uma escola na cidade de novo hamburgo ao
transitar pelas ruas do bairro histórico
de hamburgo velho
e ela faz uma relação com as aulas de
programação que ela tem no contexto da
sala de aula isso tudo acontece num
projecto denominado a cidade como espaço
de aprendizado jogos e reunificação na
concepção de espaços de convivência e
aprendizagem híbridos e multimodais para
o desenvolvimento da cidadania mas a
minha relação com o espaço e com a
aprendizagem e com as tecnologias não
começa a ir ela inicia em 1986 quando
então na 3ª série do magistério ouço
falar dos computadores pessoais que
estavam se disseminando e eu começo a
pensar como será que seria a pesagem das
crianças e dos adolescentes com o
computador
e isso me traz a são leopoldo e o curso
então o bacharel em informática
e esse processo de ambientação nesse
novo espaço vai acontecendo e no ano
seguinte eu tenho notícia de que existem
em novo hamburgo o projeto pioneiro que
trabalha um computador no processo de
aprendizagem das crianças eram projeto
pioneiro desenvolvido em parceria com o
laboratório de estudos cognitivos da
ufrgs e desenvolve ia um trabalho com
crianças da educação infantil até o 5º
ano síndrome de down deficiente mental
leve surdos meninos de rua e também
informava professoras
e foi aí então que eu disse é isso que
eu quero ingressei no processo formativo
para aprender a trabalhar com a
linguagem filosofia logo da
tartaruguinha e me tornei professora de
escola municipal meu primeiro emprego
esse processo foi se desenvolvendo e eu
fui compreendendo como é que acontecia
essa relação das crianças com a
tecnologia como é que se dava
aprendizagem numa relação entre uma
tartaruga que ficava num plano
bidimensional o seu corpo e o espaço
geográfico as tecnologias foram
evoluindo e na metade da década de 90
mais ou menos começa a se popularizar
internet e com ela começam a surgir os
primeiros mundos virtuais em três
dimensões
é o novo questionamento surge como será
que essas crianças constroem a noção de
representação do espaço quando esse
espaço não é geográfico mas é digital
entre as minhas assim eu entro no
mestrado em psicologia do
desenvolvimento para poder entender esse
processo lá desenvolvo o primeiro mundo
virtual em três dimensões
o e 89 começa com a troca uma professora
da graduação justamente numa época em
que a educação a distância começa a se
popularizar é ela começa a disseminar no
brasil e com ela então a necessidade do
desenvolvimento de ambientes virtuais de
aprendizagem como eu vim então da da
informática né já tinha se envolvendo o
uso de plantas dimensões combater
desenvolver um ambiente virtual de
aprendizado e nessa mesma época através
de uma parceria com o programa de
computação aplicada programa de
pós-graduação também desenvolvemos um a
gente comunicativo a maria e o começo a
pensar que que será que aconteceria se
eu voltasse os mundos virtuais os
ambientes virtuais de aprendizagem e os
agentes comunicativos no único ambiente
como se daria a aprendizagem do sujeito
oi e aí em 2005 nós construímos a
primeira noção daquilo que hoje a gente
compreende por educação híbrida naquele
momento a nossa compreensão do
hibridismo ele era restrito a mistura
dessas diferentes tecnologias digitais a
pesquisa evoluiu em 2010 numa parceria
com mais duas instituições gaúcha
começamos a desenvolver uma pesquisa
denominada aprendizagem de anatomia e a
fera nesse momento constituindo os 13
quilos diferentes uma de especialistas
na área da anatomia humana outros
especialistas da área da educação e
outro de especialistas na área da
ciência da computação e começamos a
desenvolver um ambiente onde dentro
desse ambiente existe o corpo humano
transparente conforme íamos
desenvolvendo os diferentes sistemas do
corpo humano esses começavam a aparecer
no nesse corpo transparente
e ali experimentando diferentes
possibilidades de imersão numa delas
vinculado ao sistema renal o avatar
entrava pela série ter podia todo o
sistema e de tempos em tempos colocamos
lá mapa sensitivos e também alguns
desafios mas totalmente despretensioso
despretensiosamente que que aconteceu
quando nós começamos a trabalhar com os
alunos eles se sentirão muito engajar o
tempo da aula acabava eles continuavam
conosco e eles começaram nos diz assim
professora mas isso parece um jogo que
bom seria se a gente tivesse no contexto
educacional esse ambiente a sala de aula
um laboratório de anatomia humana os
atlas do corpo humano o que que eles
estavam nos dizendo duas coisas
fundamentais olha um pouco mais para os
elementos de jogos no contexto da
educação porque eles podem
a aprendizagem abrir um pouco conceito
de vocês de educação híbrida porque nós
não queremos só mistura das tecnologias
digitais nós queremos as tecnologias
digitais e brisados com as tecnologias
analógicas os espaços geográficos
hibridizados com os espaços digitais as
presenças e hibridizados não são a
presença física fez tu fez ou uma
telepresença uma que tá acontecendo
conosco agora né onde é a minha própria
imagem é minha própria voz que tá
chegando remotamente no espaço
geográfico onde cada um de vocês se em
conta a presença digital e pode ser por
um perfil em rede social o personagem no
game um avatar no mundo virtual
em todas essas questões que eles nos
trouxeram nos fizeram olhar um pouco
mais para o mundo dos jogos e a
iniciamos um novo projeto e buscava
investigar então o potencial dos órgãos
e da qualificação da educação nesse
projeto criamos uma narrativa e chegava
alunos do curso de jogos digitais e da
graduação em pedagogia a emergirem no
contexto das instituições educacionais e
as escolas a fim de identificar como é
que as tecnologias estavam presentes e
que jogos que os jogos estavam presente
e como esses jovens estão aparecer que
que a gente observou nesse processo que
a significação dos conceitos preços
alunos da graduação se tornou muito mais
efetivo
bom e as escolas se aproximaram muito
mais da universidade e puderam
potencializar os seus processos nessa
mesma época surgiu o pokémon go imagina
o que vários de você sem o jogado
pokémon go né eu sempre digo que uma das
coisas boas do pokémon go foi que ele
tirou a geração sofá de casa nunca se
viu tanta criança e adolescente
circulando pela cidade e pelos espaços
públicos acompanhado de seus pais avós
tios e amigos
o que nós ficamos muito curiosa com essa
situação como é que as crianças e os
adolescentes ao jogar o pokémon go na
cidade significava nos a cidade o que
que era interessante para eles no
contexto da cidade organizamos
diferentes grupos e começamos a
transitar pela cidade e o que que nós
percebemos que a relação deles se dava
muito ponta ponto você já saiu de casa e
o pré escola da escola para aula de
música ou dança né em comunidades menos
favorecidas os pais levavam a pé ou de
bicicleta cuidando dos espaços públicos
que a maior parte das praças por exemplo
são ocupadas pelo tráfico e com isso o
que que a gente percebeu que as crianças
não tinham uma conexão forte com a
cidade não tinha uma relação de
pertencimento forte para se dar então
esse contexto todo é que consistiu nesse
projeto dá-se
e como espaço de aprendizagem e aí
começamos a criar aquilo que a gente vem
chamando do ecossistema de inovação na
educação que integra pesquisadores
professores estudantes da pós-graduação
alunos de mestrado e doutorado
professores estudantes da graduação
professores e estudantes da educação
básica diferentes espaços da cidade
incluindo organizações governamentais e
empresas dependendo do jogo ou do
projeto significado e as crianças e os
adolescentes desenvolvem então
é uma vez que o projeto é muito bem e
surge a pandemia ok não podemos mais
transitar com as crianças pelas cidades
né o que que a pandemia vivenciou para
nós nesse momento ela é evidenciou para
nós uma forte desigualdade de acesso às
tecnologias digitais e as redes de
comunicação ela evidenciou a falta de
uma cultura digital nas escolas uma
crise na precisar e uma necessidade
muito grande de formação de professor a
pantene a ela provocou o isolamento
físico mas não social continuamos as
duas socializar pelas plataformas
digitais em redes quando as crianças
transitam pela cidade quais são as
problematizações que essa cidade coloca
para ela
e como ela se conecta com a cidade com a
biodiversidade
o ou seja uma educação o ar ela é uma
educação e brisa o mundo físico o mundo
biológico e o mundo digital
possibilitando o embricamento de
diferentes modalidades
o campeando a ideia que nós temos dessas
dualismo de sujeito e objeto ou a
centralidade do processo educacional
hora no conteúdo hora no professor hora
no aluno educação é ato conectivo em
recu
o pênis hiato colectivo que hoje eu me
conecto a cada um de vocês independente
do espaço geográfico onde você se
encontram
e seria o code da vida a conexão outro
com a cidade ou a biodiversidade e
é o que me conecta
e qual é o pude da nossa vida